on friday former presidential candidate
hillary clinton spoke at bloomberg's new
economic forum in singapore she
specifically called out things like
disinformation and artificial
intelligence as things to worry about
moving forward in the future but one of
the things that caught everyone's eye
was also comments around
cryptocurrencies she said quote what
looks like a very interesting and
somewhat exotic effort to literally mine
new coins in order to trade with them
has the potential to undermining
currencies for undermining the role of
the dollar as a reserve currency for
destabilizing nations perhaps starting
with small ones but going much much
larger she explicitly is laying out that
bitcoin and cryptocurrencies are
inherently opposed to other types of
fiat currencies there are central bank
currencies that exist in the world today
i don't necessarily agree with that
there's a strong argument that i've
talked with people like microstrategy
ceo michael saylor that actually the
dollar is going to get stronger and
stronger at the exact same time that
bitcoin continues to gain adoption as
well what would that world look like
well what you would see is bitcoin
rising and continuing to be seen as a
decentralized digital global store of
value it simply would allow people to
convert any asset into bitcoin and hold
it and not be debased by any government
or central bank around the world that
store a value would preserve purchasing
power and it would increase over a long
period of time as long as demand
continued to increase but at the same
time that the global store value was
rising in prominence and gaining
adoption the u.s dollar would continue
to benefit from the collapse of
developing nation currencies as well why
well in the united states as an example
there is a tax regime that makes it very
very difficult to spend bitcoin every
time that you spend bitcoin you are
faced with capital gains taxation and so
there's a financial incentive to simply
hold the asset we know that 70 to 80 of
bitcoin is held illiquid right now
depending on how you count that
illiquidity and so ultimately what we
are watching is lots and lots of weak
fiat currencies continue to fail and
everyone around the world wants dollars
they like the idea of the stability of
the dollar the faith and credit of the
united states and so there's a world in
the future of coexistence between the
dollar and bitcoin where bitcoin serves
as the global store of value and which
is the click of a button you can convert
back and forth between dollars and
bitcoin and anytime you actually go to
spend your currency will be in dollars
the medium of exchange and so in that
world bitcoin would rise to more and
more prominence it would gain larger and
larger market share but also the dollar
would do the same and so if that was to
happen these comments around
destabilizing nations or in undermining
a reserve currency would not necessarily
be true instead what we would see is we
would see more adoption of a global
store of value it would eat into things
like real estate or fine art or other
types of store value assets but it
wouldn't necessarily eat into the dollar
being used as a medium of exchange it's
a very interesting way to look at it
it's at direct odds with the way that
hillary clinton is talking about it in
terms of her speech at the bloomberg new
economy forum in singapore on friday i
also think that there is a very deep
peace that people need to pay attention
to which is that there are lots and lots
of people who are very prominent or
experts or have tons of experience in
other areas of the world but they're not
necessarily experts on this specific
type of technology and so we have to
remember that no matter how smart you
are no matter what you've accomplished
in the past if you have not spent the
time if you've not spent hundreds if not
thousands of hours studying bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies then we have to take
their opinions with a grain of salt so
ultimately what i think will continue to
occur and what i have the highest
conviction is that bitcoin itself will
continue to rise as a global store value
the decentralized digital asset will
continue to be adopted by millions and
millions of people around the world
whether it's individuals corporations
financial institutions or nation states
like el salvador people will realize
that having a digital private property
in bitcoin where you can hold your
private keys you can store value in a
place where no one can debase it no one
can confiscate it and no one can censor
your transactions that is going to be
very very attractive in the future so we
appreciate what other people are saying
but remember bitcoin is a digital store
of value is just getting started in my
opinion